la imagen de vinagre Infante llorando
por su esposo dio la vuelta a los medios
del mundo
[Música]
su compañero Edward Caraballo uno de los
sobrevivientes del incendio que mató a
39 personas en un centro de detención de
migrantes ya está en suelo
estadounidense Caraballo fue trasladado
a un instituto sanitario en El Paso
Texas para seguir tratando el daño
pulmonar que le provocó la conflagración
vinagre Infante también emuló la
travesía que esta vez se llevó a cabo de
manera autorizada ya Edward está del
otro lado Gracias a Dios lo logramos ya
lo recibió el lado americano ya está
próximo a llegar a la al hospital en
medio de la tragedia Un fin al
afortunado Pues de valer la pena no
Porque casi mi esposo pierde la vida no
Todavía faltan varios trámites uno de
ellos ante la agencia de protección de
aduana y frontera de Estados Unidos
Mientras tanto las autoridades mexicanas
cerraron el emplazamiento migratorio
donde ocurrió el siniestro se ha tomado
la determinación de suspender desde ya
de forma definitiva la operación de la
estación migratoria de Ciudad Juárez
Chihuahua porque por lo que las personas
migrantes albergadas ahí se trasladarán
al centro integrador para el migrante
león a Vicario el migrante señalado de
presuntamente iniciar la conflagración
fue detenido era el imputado que faltaba
por aprender de las seis órdenes de
captura emitidas con relación al caso